Vous savez ce j'en ai appris ?
J'ai appris qu'il était honteux d'en parler.
J'ai appris à avoir honte de mon corps.
J'ai appris à ignorer l'existence des règles
pour être décente.
Des recherches dans diverses régions indiennes
ont montré que trois filles sur dix ne savaient rien des menstruations
avant d'avoir leurs premières règles.
Dans certains coins du Rajasthan,
ce nombre s'élève jusqu'à neuf filles sur dix.
Vous seriez surpris d'apprendre
que la plupart des filles à qui j'ai parlé
ne savaient rien des menstruations lors de leurs premières règles
et ont cru qu'elles avaient une leucémie
et qu'elles allaient bientôt mourir.
L'hygiène menstruelle est un important facteur de risque
pour les maladies des systèmes génital et reproducteur.
Mais en Inde, seuls 12 % des filles et des femmes
ont accès à un traitement hygiénique de leurs règles.
Si on calcule,
ça laisse 88 % d'entre elles
qui ne gèrent pas leurs règles de façon hygiénique.
J'étais de celles-là.
J'ai grandi dans une petite ville du nom de Garhwa, dans le Jharkhand,
où le simple achat d'une serviette hygiénique est un acte honteux.
Donc quand j'ai eu mes premières règles,
j'ai commencé par utiliser des chiffons.
Après chaque usage, je les lavais puis les réutilisais.
Mais pour les cacher,
je les conservais dans un coin sombre et humide
pour que personne n'apprenne que j'avais mes règles.
À force de lavages, les chiffons devenaient râpeux,
ce qui me donnait souvent des rougeurs et des infections.
Quand j'ai quitté la ville, ça faisait déjà cinq ans que je les portais.
Les règles m'apportèrent d'autres soucis :
les contraintes sociales imposées aux filles et aux femmes
quand elles ont leurs règles.
Je pense que vous les connaissez tous,
mais je vais en faire la liste pour ceux dont ce n'est pas le cas.
Je n'avais pas le droit de toucher ou de manger des cornichons.
Je n'avais pas le droit de m'asseoir sur le canapé ou le lit d'un parent.
Je devais laver mes draps après chaque période de règles,
même s'ils n'étaient pas tachés.
J'étais vue comme impure
et on m'interdisait de prier ou de toucher un objet d'importance religieuse.
Vous verrez des indications à l'entrée des temples
interdisant l'entrée aux filles et aux femmes ayant leurs règles.
Paradoxalement,
c'est souvent la femme la plus âgée
qui impose ces contraintes aux plus jeunes de la famille.
Après tout, elles ont elles-même appris à les accepter comme la norme.
Et en l'absence de toute intervention,
c'est le mythe et l'idée fausse
qui se propagent de génération en génération.
Pendant mes années de travail dans ce domaine,
j'ai entendu parler de filles
qui devaient manger et nettoyer leurs plats séparément.
Elles n'ont pas le droit de se laver pendant leurs règles ;
dans certains foyers, elles sont tenues à l'écart de la famille.
Près de 85 % des Indiennes
obéissaient à un ou plus de ces usages pendant leurs règles chaque mois.
Savez-vous l'effet que ça produit
pour l'amour-propre et l'assurance d'une jeune fille ?
Le traumatisme psychologique que ça implique,
qui nuit à sa personnalité,
ses performances scolaires,
et tous les aspects de sa croissance pendant ces années formatrices ?
Pendant 13 ans, j'ai religieusement suivi ces usages,
jusqu'à ce qu'une discussion avec mon conjoint, Tuhin,
change pour toujours ma conception des règles.
En 2009, Tuhin et moi suivions une formation supérieure en design.
Nous sommes tombés amoureux,
j'étais suffisamment à l'aise pour parler de règles avec lui.
Tuhin savait très peu de choses des règles.
(Rires)
Il était abasourdi d'apprendre
que les filles ressentaient des crampes douloureuses
et saignaient tous les mois.
(Rires)
Oui.
Il était choqué à l'idée
des contraintes imposées à celles qui avaient leurs règles
par leurs propres familles et par la société.
Pour m'aider à surmonter mes crampes,
il allait sur internet pour s'informer sur les règles.
Quand il a partagé ses découvertes avec moi,
j'ai compris à quel point j'en savais peu moi-même.
Nombre de mes croyances s'avérèrent être des mythes.
Alors nous nous sommes demandés :
si nous, éduqués comme nous l'étions,
étions si mal renseignés sur les règles,
il devait exister des millions de filles qui l'étaient tout autant.
Pour étudier –
pour mieux cerner le problème,
j'ai fait un an de recherche pour étudier le manque de savoir sur les règles
et ses causes.
On tend souvent à croire
que l'absence d'information à ce sujet est un problème rural,
mais mes recherches ont montré
que le même problème existe aussi en ville.
Et il existe également parmi les classes urbaines éduquées.
En parlant avec des parents et des professeurs,
j'ai compris que beaucoup souhaitaient informer les filles
avant qu'elles commencent leurs cycles.
Et –
il leur manquait un vrai moyen de communication.
Et, à cause du tabou,
ils ressentent un blocage et une honte à évoquer le sujet.
Aujourd'hui, les filles ont leurs règles dès 11 ans
mais l'école ne leur parle des règles
que vers 14-15 ans.
Et puisque c'est tabou,
les professeurs font carrément l'impasse sur le sujet.
Donc l'école n'apprend pas les règles aux filles,
les parents n'en parlent pas.
À qui s'adressent-elles ?
Depuis vingt ans,
rien n'a changé.
J'ai partagé mes résultats avec Tuhin et on s'est demandé :
et si nous pouvions créer quelque chose
qui aiderait les filles à s'informer elles-mêmes,
qui aiderait les parents et les professeurs
à parler plus librement des règles avec les jeunes filles ?
Pendant mes recherches,
j'ai récolté de nombreuses histoires.
Des histoires vécues par des filles pendant leurs règles.
Ces histoires pourraient éveiller la curiosité et l'intérêt des filles
et les inciter à parler de règles dans leur cercle privé.
Voilà ce que nous voulions.
Nous voulions quelque chose qui rendent les filles curieuses
et qui les incite à se renseigner.
Nous voulions utiliser ces histoires pour expliquer les règles aux filles.
Donc nous avons décidé de créer une bande dessinée
dans laquelle les personnages illustreraient ces histoires
et qui parlerait des règles d'une façon drôle et engagée.
Pour représenter les différentes phases de la puberté,
nous avons trois personnages.
Pinki, qui n'a pas encore ses règles,
Jiya, qui a ses première règles dans le livre
et Mira, qui a déjà eu ses premières règles.
Puis il y a un quatrième personnage, Priya Didi.
C'est par elle que les filles apprennent les différents aspects de la croissance
et la manière de gérer l'hygiène menstruelle.
En réalisant ce livre, nous avons fait très attention
à ce qu'aucune des illustrations ne soient répréhensibles
et que l'ouvrage soit respectueux de la culture.
En testant notre prototype, on a constaté que les filles adoraient ce livre.
Elles avaient envie de lire
et d'en apprendre plus sur les règles d'elles-mêmes.
Parents et profs se sentaient prêts à parler des règles
aux jeunes filles qui lisaient le livre,
et parfois, même les garçons voulaient lire le livre.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
La BD a permis de créer un environnement
où les règles cessaient d'être un tabou.
Nombre de volontaires ont emporté ce prototype pour éduquer les filles
et pour mener des ateliers d'information dans différentes régions indiennes.
Un des volontaires a présenté le prototype à des jeunes moines
dans un monastère de Ladakh.
Nous avons finalisé l'ouvrage, appelé « Menstrupedia Comic »
et l'avons lancé en septembre dernier.
Et à date,
plus de 4 000 filles ont été instruites grâce à ce livre en Inde...
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
... et dans 10 pays différents.
On traduit constamment la BD dans diverses langues
et on travaille avec des organisations locales
pour rendre le livre accessible dans plusieurs pays.
15 écoles indiennes
ont inclus la BD dans leur programme scolaire
pour instruire les filles à propos des règles.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis impressionnée de voir le nombre de volontaires,
particuliers, parents, enseignants, directeurs,
se sont rassemblés
et ont apporté ce nouveau savoir à leur communauté,
ont fait en sorte que les filles apprennent les règles au bon âge
et que le tabou soit brisé.
Je rêve d'un avenir où les règles ne seraient ni une malédiction,
ni une maladie,
mais un changement attendu dans la vie d'une fille.
Et j'aimerais...
(Applaudissements)
Et j'aimerais terminer
sur une petite demande aux parents dans la salle.
Chers parents,
si vous avez honte des règles,
vos filles auront honte aussi.
Alors, s'il-vous-plaît, soyez pour les règles.
(Rires)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)